Bộ công thương và bán hành thông thương số mấy chiến, quy định về ta ứng cho quy định ngồn gà săng gầu từng
một nân xanh nhả nước. Chức lập quy và hành trả tạc ứng và được bộ công thương
măng hành nhằm bảo đảm một công, ồ định gián như liệu trong buổi cạnh mới.
Không thương sẽ quy định được kết nhất của li, kẹp chà, giám sát, kẹp toán và quyết toán
đường với hoa sợ tạc ứng, chi sử dụng, chức lập và hành trả quy định
một giá săng gầu từng một nân xanh nhả nước.
Các thương nhảnh đầu mỗi chiến dành săng gầu, những hành thương mại nơi mở cải quan thông qua và cắt tụ trước.
Cá nhá liệt quan sẽ chiếu các lập tự thông thư đây trong quá trình sử dụng.
Tổng tiền chi quy trong kí doanh được tính theo mất chi gió cơ quan của li công bố,
nhán với sản lượng tư thụt tự tế. Đồng thời, việc trích lập quy và hành trong năm ngày làm việc sau mỗi kí doanh.
Chức ló chính phủ đã bán hành nghĩ quyết chuyển hai chi tạc ứng cho quy định oàn trả săng gầu.
Tự muôn tăng thư nhân sách trường ơn năm hành nghĩ không trọng hai bây lâm.
Đồng ý vổ xuống tảng nhiên tỷ đồng dự tỏa chiến nhân sách nhả nước năm hành nghĩ không trọng hai bây lâm.
Chó bộ công thương để tạo ứng quy định oàn trả săng gầu.